Background voice: Let's
think about how we would
have accounted for things,
if instead of renting our
building for $200,000,
instead we bought the
building for $2,000,000,
how would that showed up …
how would that have shown up
from an accounting profit point of view
and an economic profit point of view?
We're going to buy our
building for $2,000,000.
That is the market value of our building
at the beginning of our period,
at the beginning of year 1.
Let's say, at the end of year 1,
so this is year 1 right
over here, that occurs.
Maybe, to a large degree,
this is because I used the building,
there was a lot of traffic in there.
Maybe it was a brand new building before
and now it's essentially kind of ...
the building itself has
taken some wear and tear.
Because of that, the market
value of the building
is now, 1.9 million dollars.
Essentially, through this year,
the building's value has
depreciated by $100,000.
We'll say the depreciation is $100,000.
Notice, I didn't pay anyone that $100,000.
It was not an explicit opportunity cost,
but this really is an opportunity cost,
because this $100,000
is the opportunity cost
of not selling the building a year ago.
Instead, using that building,
I have essentially lost out on $100,000.
That's not all that I have lost out on.
I have also lost out on
the ability to invest
this $2,000,000 in other things.
Maybe I could have
invested the $2,000,000
at a 5% rate and gotten
some interest on it.
I also have the opportunity cost,
opportunity cost
of capital, of not
investing that $2,000,000
some place else.
The opportunity cost of capital,
let's say I could have
gotten 5% on my $2,000,000.
5% of 2,000,000 is $100,000.
My opportunity cost of
capital is $100,000.
Another way to think about it is,
let's just say that I buy the building
and I sell it at the end of the year.
Then, I would have literally lost $100,000
on that transaction
and although I might have used it,
so I got some value out of it,
and I would have lost another $100,000
by not having that money
invested in some other use
during that period.
These are the 2 non-explicit cost
that will come into ...
that would show up in
our profit statements.
Now, depreciation is something
that is accounted for
by accountants.
When you look at a company's financials,
you will see something
called a depreciation.
Which is a measure of, how are you ...
You're kind of using
up your capital goods,
you are using up your building,
you are using up your equipment,
you are using up your vehicles,
or whatever else you might have.
Economist are very pure
about depreciation.
They say, what was the market value
at the beginning of the period,
what is the market value at the end,
the difference is how
much it has depreciated.
This is kind of ...
it's actually almost a more natural way.
In accounting, and I
won't go into the details,
there are many ways to
depreciate something.
You might be able to say,
"Well, if the thing is worth $2,000,000"
"and if it's going to last me 10 years,"
"I can depreciate $100,000 a year,"
"or actually $200,000 a year."
2,000,000 divided by 10 years.
There is different incentives based on
if you are the owner of a firm,
of how you depreciate.
You might want to actually want to have
a lot of depreciation for tax purposes,
so that you can somehow
hide a profit or whatever.
For the sake of this video,
we're going to assume
that both the accountants
and the economist
will mark off $100,000 of depreciation,
if we were to buy the building.
Let's redo our 2 financial statements,
the accounting version
and the economic version.
In the accounting version ...
Let me copy and paste all of this.
Copy and let me go down here and paste it.
Let me paste it.
Now, we don't have any rent expense.
Instead of renting the building,
we've gone off and we've
bought the building.
Let me get rid of that.
Our rent expense is now going to be 0,
is now going to be 0.
We do have a depreciation expense.
I'll write that in another color.
We do have a depreciation
expense of $100,000.
We don't think about the
opportunity cost of capital.
What we could have done ...
This is opportunity cost of capital.
What we could have done
with that $2,000,000
that we used to buy the building.
Our pretax profit,
our pretax accounting profit,
pretax profit from an
accounting point of view,
is going to be … Let's see, 50 minus 200
is 300, minus another ...
Let me make sure that I get this right.
I have …
Actually, it's gotten better,
because my rent was 200
and now I only have a depreciation of 100.
It's 50 minus 350 gives me
a pretax profit of $150,000.
That was because I was renting it for more
and now my depreciation, based on how ...
what happened with the market rate,
actually changed less
than what my rent would have been.
The economic profit,
at least based on the way
we've done the numbers here
it will actually come out neutral.
Which it should,
because really economic profit,
we're just trying to decide,
does it make sense for us to
run this business in this way.
When we look at the economic profit ...
Let's copy and paste this again.
Let me copy just this part.
Copy and paste.
Maybe if things actually did improve,
when we actually changed
whether we owned or rent,
then that would say that's the
more economic way to do it.
Let's say that it's year
2 or this is year 1 again.
Now we're doing, this is
economic profit, year 1.
Our food is the same.
Our labor is the same.
Our rent disappears.
Let me get rid of that.
Let me get rid of the rent.
The rent is now going to be 0.
We now own our building.
Rent is 0.
These are all our explicit cost.
These are direct payments
of money to someone else.
Now, let's think about our implicit cost.
Implicit cost.
We still have the same implicit cost
that we had up here.
We have the wages foregone.
We talked about maybe I was a doctor
and I'm not working as a
doctor to run this restaurant,
so my wages foregone are $150,000.
Wages foregone are $150,000.
Actually, I think ...
Wages lost are $150,000.
Now, we have the
depreciation on top of that.
I'll do this in magenta
to show what is new.
We have the depreciation of $100,000.
On top of that,
we have the opportunity cost of capital.
The return we could have
gotten on that $2,000,000,
that instead we used to buy the building.
I'll call it OCC,
opportunity cost of capital,
in this situation was
the 5% of $2,000,000,
another $100,000.
The way that I've worked
out the numbers here,
we didn't have to spend 200,000 on rent,
but we increased our implicit
cost by owning the building,
by 200,000, so it all comes out the same.
We still get what we
got in the previous one,
of an economic profit
of negative $100,000.
Negative 100,000 of economic profit.
Economic profit.
This of course was accounting profit.
I wanted to really just highlight in this,
is that you don't get kind of a freebie
on the economic profit
when you decide to buy
instead of rent, or rent verses buy.
There are still ways of accounting for,
essentially, the opportunity cost
of doing any of these actions.